we're going to talk about something that
I know is so important to David and I
good business where we are taking a look
at how businesses can do better Paul
Tudor Jones has just launched just
capital aiming to rank top US companies
based on what is important to the public
just is surveying Americans to see what
matters most Paul talk to us about this
initiative and welcome well thank you so
much for having me here let me first
thank you for hosting the National Fish
and Wildlife Foundation benefited we
could go for us it was our biggest event
ever and your passion came through and
you were spectacular thank you Paul well
your passion is not just to fish and
wildlife it's to new york city's poorest
and it's also to investing so talk to us
about what you're doing right now so
just capital is really I think it's
larger mission is to try to find the
right balance between all the various
stakeholders and how we do business in
the country today so you have
shareholders which we talk about all the
time you certainly talk about all the
time on Bloomberg News but we also have
employees customers local communities
the environment and I think what just
capitals mission is and the just index
in particular is to try to bring again
dialogue and balance among all those
competing interests right now probably
we have so much of a focus on profits
and shareholders interest sometimes to
the detriment of the other very
important stakeholders and this is
really an effort to give everyone a
voice the thought makes perfect sense
but you've been pretty stark in your
terms you've said that we're losing the
humanity in capitalism and you say this
as a capitalist who believes in
capitalism exactly how bad is the
problem well I think clearly the topic
of the day is income inequality it's a
it is something that is probably I think
the biggest social challenge we have I
think it's something that can really
harm this country if we don't deal with
it the question is is how do you deal
with that and of course there's public
sector solutions and there's private
sector solutions
and when the idea of just capital first
service surfaced which is about three
years ago really with a student and
Deepak Chopra's class at Columbia who
said what if we put together an index of
those companies who are pursuing justice
and the way they operate the most and we
had this great index that people could
invest in and as Deepak and on another
gentleman named Paul see how I began to
talk about it it became clear that this
really was a good idea I'll be frank
with you I've been on Wall Street 40
years I didn't even at the time know
that there's a 4 trillion dollar
socially responsible investing business
already around that which of course
speaks to the fact that we really are
too focused on profits as opposed to the
other things that are really important
and if you didn't even know that that
existed and you are clearly someone who
is ahead of the curve how are we going
to get people to care when we talk about
shareholders they've got a much bigger
megaphone than then people going to
whole food saying they want to buy you
know products that do good things right
well so again this is this is this whole
development of this idea I kind of liken
it to when the internet was first
created Wow well I'm just saying you had
a professor at UCLA who first connected
to menlo park little did he have any
idea that the ARPANET at that point time
would morph into what it is today right
so when when Deepak and I began looking
into this when the whole team began
looking into us we thought this is an
investment vehicle but then we realized
what we're really talking here is about
harnessing the power of the private
sector and the private sector is 14
trillions so you don't need is four
times the size of the public sector so
addressing something like income
inequality yes you can try public
selector solutions yes you can try the
tax code that l that's all right but the
elephants with room is moving the
private sector both on the consumption
side
where employees work what kind of
products we make how companies manage
themselves in the boardroom that's where
you're really going to have substantive
change yeah now there are different
views on this as you know I mean there's
a lot of people who are coming to your
view there's a real problem income
inequality some people think like in
Earned Income Tax Credit could be a
solution to it when we talked to Warren
Buffett recently who is very concerned
about income inequality and who suggests
earn come it earned income tax credit is
the way to go I think we have a bit of
that we have an enormous way rich
accommodative it I mean well over 50,000
of gdp per capita it's six times in real
terms what it was what I was born
imagine that one person's lifetime 641
and I mean it blows your mind yeah he
was talking about rich the economy is
but he's very concerned it's not getting
shared with everybody right but again he
thinks an earned income tax credit is
the way to go you think this private
sector approach would be more effective
well look Rome you know rome wasn't
built in a day and at one built by one
carpenter right there going to be many
tactics to address this and certainly
our idea of creating an index of the
thousand largest companies in America
and ranking them from one to a thousand
based on their justness is but one
tactic but I think it's an important
tech